[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host Paul and if you've been
craving some new Spider-Man spin-off
trailer details then this is the video
you've been Hunter ring
okay the first look at Craven the hunter
was officially shown at cinemacon last
night and we have a lot of details and
descriptions of what's in the trailer to
talk about Aaron Taylor Johnson is
playing the infamous Bounty Hunter and
from the Sands of it it might actually
break the curse of Spider-Man spin-offs
I actually like Venom but I'm not going
to mention it because every time I do
our editor Mac kicks off anyway
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down what we learned from the
event and also discussing what we think
will be happening in the film if you
enjoy the video then please hit the
thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns like this every
day by the way huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get in a craving
the hunter now from the event we know
that the film's gonna be R-rated and
that the first look is packed with a lot
of over-the-top action in Gore Aaron
Taylor Johnson takes Center Stage
Jenny's been really building a name for
himself in the last couple of years it's
got to the point now that he's
apparently the front runner for James
Bond and if you told me 10 years ago
that Kick-Ass would be 007 I'd say sure
an Avatar 2 will make over a billion
[Music]
here we are anyway trailer footage
descriptions often Get Lost in
Translation so some things might be
slightly altered here however from what
I've been able to gather this is
basically what happens in the teaser
Rhino will be making a big appearance in
it and with Sony not using Spider-Man
and their villain spin-offs they've
instead opted to have him as the main
focus Craven is of course a hunter and
the character actually made his name in
the comics by attempting to track down
the Webhead and claim him as a prize in
Craven's last turn he actually managed
to accomplish this as well and he ended
up burying Spider-Man alive which led to
him having to crawl out of a grave in
one of the best comic book covers ever
in the Ultimate Comics Craven was a sort
of Steve Irwin reality TV star except
for that he hunted the animals instead
of being the best best Bloody bloke has
ever been and he was trying to prove
himself as the best tunnel that there
ever was which has been a key component
of the character whenever we've met him
in the comics he's been fully
established however this movie will act
as a sort of origin story for him and
we'll see not only is younger years but
also his father who'll be played by
Russell Crowe now the footage apparently
begins in the countryside where number
of poachers are seemingly closing in on
a location Craven pops up out of nowhere
wielding his classic machete and he'll
cut them up in what's meant to be an
extremely gory scene the description for
the footage just says lots of blood and
this will instantly give us the idea
that this movie is here and it's our
writing anyway at this point we hear
Russell Crowe as his father giving
narration towards the general theme of
the film he basically gives lines about
what he is and what he'll become and he
closes it out by saying that both he and
his son are predators although the Rhino
is betrayed as the villain in the
trailer it is possible that Crow's
character might end up becoming the big
bad who's potentially putting his son
through the paces in order to try and
craft him into the world's greatest
hunter potentially he's in cahoots with
a rhino or something like that but we'll
obviously see in the movie anyway from
here we go to a snowy action scene
before then moving to his City this
gives the idea that this is gonna be a
globetrotting adventure with Craven
training his skills in both Arctic and
urban jungles but told throughout it
that he's just another man who's looking
for a trophy and again this suggests he
hasn't made his name yet and instead
he's just out there on the hunt trying
to build his name the trailer is meant
to be quite short and we have a couple
more shots with one including Craven
sitting in an office chair before he
Spears someone who walks into the room
he also bites a guy's nose off during
this and lastly someone gets stuck in a
medieval trap which brutally kills them
I'm a bit confused over when this
actually happens in the trailer as some
reports have said that this is what
opens it with the poachers and that
Craven actually spits the nose out
directly at the camera in a way it's
meant to be very over the top and Sonya
pushing hard to get that ring for the
film now I wasn't able to place when
this part happens in the trailer but
we're also meant to see his classic
comic accurate vest Craven Paul said out
of a chest at one point so potentially
this belonged to his father or maybe
something that pops up in a
post-creating you know Sony loves
showing their post credit scenes in the
trailer because they just can't help
themselves but yeah that's meant to be
what happens in the movie now apparently
we end with a tease of the Rhino and get
a couple of action scenes with us also
seeing what's happening with the
character power wise when he appeared in
The Amazing Spider-Man 2 the villain of
course had the iconic robot armor
however they're taking a different
approach for this film and instead he'll
be achieving his abilities through his
serum immensity Craven encounter the
character and he then injects himself
with a serum from here we get a shot of
his arm morphing into a giant Rhino Fist
and this is before the rest of his body
transforms at this point he'll become a
giant Rhino monster and it'll be up to
Craven to take him down now him
basically being Rhino man also sets up
the fact that he might one day hunt
Spider-Man sort of animal themed
villains and with Spider-Man having a
lot of them they they could even have
him going toe-to-toe with other animal
inspired characters you've got Scorpion
Black Cat Doctor Octopus the vulture and
so on so if things go well you might
even get other villains like that for
the character to face off against and
the trailer ends with the tagline
nothing survives the hunt and this is
very much giving us the idea that Craven
will somewhat lose himself in carrying
out these Deeds gonna be really
interesting to see how it all plays out
with that and I think that Aaron Taylor
Johnson's a really great get for the
film Sony have pulled in JC Chando to
direct and in case you don't know who
that is he was behind the film a most
violent year at Cinema Khan Sony also
apparently made it clear that they are
still planning to pull together all the
Spider-Man spin-off characters even
though morbius was somewhat midbeus now
it was terrible wasn't it anyway this is
clearly Sony finally embracing what they
need to do and just saying it they
didn't even include 50 Spider-Man easter
eggs in the trailer that they're then
gonna edit out the actual film and I'm
hoping that this shows that they're
confident in it and they're just going
yeah give it an R rating now I actually
also like Venom 2 mate yeah don't kick
off but it baffled me that they did a
Carnage story that was PG-13 this guy's
a serial killer with one of the most
messed up backstories in comics and they
turned it right down to try and appeal
to everyone I really think that they
should have leaned into that and I'm
glad that it at least sounds like
they're doing that with this film
Deadpool and Logan have shown that you
can do already comic book films and have
them do well I'm hoping that if this one
succeeds that it will help become more
normalized in this genre we know that
Deadpool 3 will be alrighted as well and
if that is well then I'm hoping it opens
the doors for films like the MCU blade
movie to receive that rating too comic
book movies are in a weird place at the
moment and it does seem like disinterest
in them hasn't been like this since the
early naughties Shazam 2 bomb pretty
hard and quantumania hasn't turned a
proper yet I don't think so it's gonna
be really interesting to see if this can
Garner an audience by doing things
differently I think the main thing with
it is that there's just not enough
movies breaking the mold right now but
doing stuff like this like pushing for
all ratings making Batman a gritty crime
Noir Joker and so on you know these
types of movies that take chances
actually manage to stand out and it
shows that the franchise is growing with
its audience we're hitting a point now
with the first MCU movie was released 15
years ago and that first Iron Man movie
actually seems way more mature than a
lot of the stuff that we're getting now
so fingers crossed this helps to make
the movie better and hopefully wins some
good World towards the Sony Universe
because outside of the spider-verse
films yeah those last couple of movies
have been a bit lackluster not to me
though obviously let me know your
thoughts below and if this makes you
more or less hyped for the movie it was
also some Madame web footage apparently
shown as well but I'm still getting
clarification on what happened in that
so I'll keep you up to date on it when I
know for definite now we are in a
competition right now and giving away
the quantumania steelbook to three
subscribers on the 15th of May all you
have to do to be when the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the teaser who paint the comments at
random on the 15th and the winners are
the last one are on screen right now
save that to you then message me on
Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of
quantumania which will be linked on
screen right now went through the whole
film and found lots of Easter eggs that
haven't been another breakdown so
definitely head over there if you want
to see some of the good things in that
movie if not then thanks for singing
through the video I've been poor and
hopefully I see you next time you take
care peace